représentant de l'état du siaap élus et
associations ils se sont une nouvelle
fois réunis pour faire le point sur les
conséquences de l'incendié survenu le 3
juillet dernier à la station d'épuration
d'achères souvenez-vous plusieurs tonnes
de poissons morts avaient été repêchés
dans la seine
si la cause de l'incendié n'est pas
encore trouvé à ce jour l'activité de
traitement des eaux usées fonctionne à
plus de 90% et d'amélioration
substantielle va avoir lieu à partir du
14 novembre puis des travaux
complémentaires vont être engagés
notamment pour la détection incendie et
ces travaux seront terminés au 28
février prochain et puis nous aurons un
retour progressif à la pleine capacité
mais en effet ça prend du temps environ
quatre années encore le préfet des
yvelines a par ailleurs prescrits et
plusieurs audits concernant notamment la
sécurité
de son côté le siaap le syndicat
interdépartemental pour l'assainissement
de l'agglomération parisienne se veut
rassurant ce qui s'est passé de lors
d'un incident c'est qu'on n'a pas pu
accepter les eaux d'égout qui arrivait
avec les pollutions humaines et qui a
consommé l'oxygène dans la seine
dégradants et c'est le manque d'oxygène
dans la seine qui a fait que les
poissons sont morts par asphyxie mais
n'y a pas eu de produits chimiques dans
la scène donc on voit bien que ces
équipements soient absolument nécessaire
avec l'audit doit travailler aussi à
nous faire avancer sur
comment avoir redondance ou du moins
schéma de secours en cas de nouveau
problème
en plus de ces audits un plan
particulier d'intervention sera mise en
place
sa consultation est possible jusqu'au 5
novembre sur le site de la préfecture
des yvelines ainsi que dans les communes
concernées
une cinquième réunion est également
prévue à la mi-décembre en
sous-préfecture de saint-germain-en-laye